Alden ring may be getting new locations
and Ray tracing according to a new
report so let's talk about it
Alden ring was the loudest game in early
2022 but in the past couple months from
software has been fairly quiet however
now the game has a new patch available
that rebalances PVP lays the groundwork
for a wider PVP Shuffle and has added
hidden references to new maps if the
back-to-back use of player vs player
didn't give it away patch 1.07 is almost
exclusively multiplayer Focus the
biggest change is the addition of
separate damage scaling for PVP battles
a change that the game's Community has
lobbied for since its release most PVP
years contend that the damage values on
many of Eldon Ring's most popular
weapons and Ashes of War are inflated
which leads to short battles where a
single mistake means life or death
besides this the patch includes a
general Nerf to all ashes of War as well
as many adjustments specific to certain
weapons as for the teas of new locations
prolific Souls hacker Lance McDonald
claims this pack match also adds
references to maps that aren't in the
game yet on a raw code level it also
adds some code that appears to be
related to Ray tracing options that
don't exist yet in the game's menu
either this would seem to indicate that
fresh single player content for the game
is coming at some point soon though you
shouldn't hold your breath just yet
there is no timetable for the Alden ring
DLC at this point though considering the
game has sold almost 17 million copies
in six months it seems like it's
inevitable not to mention the game
awards are fast approaching my
prediction is that we see Elden ring
sweep and take home a lot of awards and
then drop the DLC news at the event I'll
even take it a step further and say it's
available the day of the announcement
but it's not a surprise because it leaks
early by showing up in a console
storefront Before It's Quickly taken
down actually I won't even limit it to
just console storefronts let's include a
possible league on Steam as well and
speaking of the store named after water
vapor the Steam mobile app has gotten a
a complete aesthetic overhaul and a
bunch of new features to boot including
new login options and remote downloads
as in previous releases the Steam mobile
app enables two-factor authentication on
Steam however more login options are now
available including scanning a QR code
with your phone in the app or sign in
confirmation you can now also customize
notifications enabling you to receive
notice whenever a game on your wishlist
goes on sale or you get a friend request
the app also lets you manage Account
Details like the PC application you can
browse Community Pages news your library
and the store on the go none of that is
new but improvements have been made to
the browsing interface and you can now
download games on your PC remotely using
the Steam Market and trading now
requires confirmations making
transactions more secure in theory the
app can now also support multiple
accounts and you can manage devices with
access to your steam account from the
app hit the comment section let us know
what you want from held in ring DLC
we'll see you tomorrow